I have to say I believe whatever is
happening to fugetsu might be a side
effect of trying to leave the ship a
restriction placed by the succession
wall that you can't leave unless you get
got like what she's going through now
that is an interesting idea so my
hypothesis in the chapter review was
that fugetsu was cursed by one of
Camilla's have-nots however this idea is
worth exploring because when kacho and
fugetsu tried to escape one of kacho's
final thoughts on this world was leaving
the ship doesn't mean Escape but to
death and against fugetsu did
technically leave the ship so her death
may not be as instantaneous as contras
but this could still be some form of
punishment for breaking the conditions
of the succession War a much more slow
acting punishment I mean I say much more
she's practically dead and it's only
been a couple of days so that's still
pretty fast but if that is the case I
think forgets his chances of living are
even worse than if she would have been
cursed by one of Camilla's Legion
because this whole contest is one big
invocation of post-mortem nen the
succession War and the cedar in the
facilitator are all fueled by the former
Kings of kakin as well as hundreds maybe
even thousands of former princes had
been sacrificed for the good of the
Kingdom since its Inception that also
may go some way towards explaining the
phenomena that forgets who is in a
mechanism that I'm going to describe as
somehow actually getting more powerful
as her life force streams most notably
she now seems to be able to use Secret
Door both ways without kacho and several
times a day although here is another
Sinister possibility fugetsu may be
doing this to herself she may be quite
literally cursing herself because using
Secret Door costs a colossal amount of
Aura to use at least comparatively to
what fugetsu can generate so if she's
using this door multiple times per day
then she could be quite literally
killing herself by spending more life
force than she can generate and it's
truly tragic because fugetsu believes
that she's doing all of this to protect
can't show who has already died to
protect fugetsu who is now about to die
to protect kacho sort of like a reverse
Romeo and Juliet they killed themselves
because they thought the other was dead
but in this case kacho and fugetsu may
both be dying to ensure the life of the
other which just ends up in double death
instead of double life double F would be
much more preferable it's not too
dissimilar from how gone used his own
then during the palace Invasion pushing
himself Beyond his limits but in a very
self-destructive way and of course gone
also essentially placed a nen curse on
himself that took the power of a dark
consonant Calamity to exercise so look
I'm not as convinced anymore that this
curse is definitely Camilla's doing I
still think it's a strong chance because
everything lines up with the have-nots
but it could also be punishment for
leaving the contest Arena or it could
even be fugatsu cursing herself
whichever one it turns out to be though
it's still a curse which is a problem
because nanax assists are in very short
supply I am so happy to see that
apparently some of kacho's conscience
has survived in her guardian beast she
cares so much for her sister that she
doesn't even care about her own death
it's always interesting to see what I'm
going to refer to as an
anthropomorphized ninbeast and it's not
unprecedented in fact the first thought
that comes to my mind is biskey's
masseuse named cookie she was a
completely humanoid nenbeast but even
then this lingering will of can't show
is on a completely different level for
all intents and purposes it is a
self-aware nen clone and that would
bring up all sorts of identity questions
but also technically this is another use
of post-mortem nim so I do wonder if the
kacho Clone has any sort of enhanced
abilities or if that postpartum nature
is currently what's impacting fugetsu
remembering that without you and secret
door are linked abilities but part of me
really thinks that Togashi is setting us
up for some pretty hard-hitting tragedy
here with fugetsu already having
somewhat experienced the death of
Karcher this may end up being quite the
sickening fate if the nen can't show
then goes on to witness the death of
fugetsu like Conjuring the ultimate
impossible scenario for despair where
both of them need to experience the
other one dying and I believe that if
fugatsu dies then the nenkacho
disappears because the conditions for
without you are stipulated until death I
think it would be cool if the bodyguards
and staff playing along with the roles
Prince Tyson gave them started to
actually become those identities and
gained Powers accordingly like the
Hitman that only remembers how to use a
gun or the alien guy he could probably
have some crazy Powers so that's a very
interesting idea because that's the
thing about men it responds to a
person's need desires and emotions and
very notably Prince Tyson's Guardian
Spirit Beast directly manipulates the
latter it's an emissive type that grants
happiness to followers of Tyson in
exchange for their Aura I believe
izanavi actually likened it to a Spirit
Bomb from Dragon Ball So Tyson
admittedly unknowingly is siphoning off
the life force of her followers to
increase her own personal power which I
guess is kind of in line with Tyson's
mission of Love changing the world
because the love and devotion of her
followers is making her very powersome
but with this emotional nen manipulation
if her bodyguards were to become nen
users then naturally they would develop
abilities based on what they think would
help Tyson the most and right now what
best suits Tyson for the bodyguards is
to play the roles they've been assigned
like madwig the amnesiac assassin who
looks shockingly like fourth princess
radnik but he could develop an ability
to say conjure and then gun but every
bullet he fires erases a memory from his
mind but he's happy to do that because
Prince Tyson's nenbeast is directly
manipulating his happiness but even
without then I think that these gods are
in real danger of losing themselves
because again the more devoted they are
the more happiness they receive in
return and I've been told that happiness
is good a good feeling I have yet to
experience it
I could talk but eventually surely most
people would choose to take the path
that makes them the happiest even if it
means abandoning what they are and thus
Tyson's bodyguards would just maybe
start to live the role but that's
another reason why I'm very skeptical of
Tyson her whole gimmick is about
storytelling and role play all of her
guards have a very specific part in
Tyson's reverse Harem play so when I see
her having a genuinely opening and
emotional moment in chapter 400 the
skeptic in me just has to wonder if this
is also all part of the play I'm not
saying she's some Grand evil mastermind
or even evil at all I just don't trust
that this situation is a straightforward
and innocent as it's being presented to
us because Tyson is at heart a
Storyteller and in this chapter she
certainly does tell the very good story
one convincing enough that izanavi is
now for his own reasons pretty set on
having the king read the book of Tyson
and as I mentioned in the chapter review
he is now an accidental disciple of
Tyson so longy revealed that they were
already a nen user to karapika this is
huge because in in theory they would be
the fourth user furykov noticed in the
room making them the most likely user of
silent majority alright I don't want to
get too deeply into this because silent
majority is oh it's a big topic it's the
sort of thing that really does need a
video of its own it's a confusing but
stupidly intriguing ability that's
happening right now but this commenter
is very potentially correct in chapter
372 we spent a lot of time Inside the
Mind brain of furykov who identified a
series of secret net users attending
karapika's class and the final one which
was not made known to us as readers was
the user who fioricoft reduced is most
likely to be the silent majority
assassin and with the Revelation that oh
longy is already a nen user how about
that then that would set us up for a
pretty one-to-one correlation and just
as a sight recap longi is of course one
of fifth Prince to pepa's bodyguards and
one of the two that was sent krapika's
Nan class along with mayor however mayor
was definitely not an end user prior to
the classes and Prince de beppa herself
was unaware of Nan prior to the contest
which means that no matter what longhi
has been keeping secrets now that's
important because the user of silent
majority has a hit list of people that
were given to them which I imagine
wouldn't have been given by tibeta
because she obviously didn't know about
nen if she doesn't know about nange
can't know about silent majority and if
she doesn't know about silent majority
she can't write out a list of people to
kill so that would potentially imply
that longy is working on behalf of
someone else however and I really want
to stress this that is only if longy is
the user I'm not gonna lie it's been an
awfully long time since I went over the
whole silent majority situation so I
can't pull all of the details off the
top of my head but this is a potentially
groundbreaking development that only
signifies further danger for karapika
our melody in danger not my favorite
character please uh yeah Melody are in
danger sewed so much danger that's why
the Justice Bureau is currently holding
her in custody because as soon as she
gets out then those printers will
immediately pounce some may pounce like
friendly cats wanting Friendly Pets
whilst others will pounce like more
combat trained attacker I mean in
chapter 400 it's even said that the
first prince has guards stationed right
outside waiting for Melody and I don't
think they'd kill her at least at least
not immediately because right now Melody
is more like some sort of coveted weapon
most of the princes are interested in
using her but also they probably fear
her being used against them so Melody is
a massive Target right now potentially
even more of a Target than karapiko
which is very impressive because that
boy went to a whole lot of effort to
make himself the focal point of this
entire contest on a bit of a meta note
though I also think that this is a
really cool use of the melody character
because she is one of the very few
people in this series who is just pure
and good and nice and stuff and I like
her don't don't do bad things to melody
or else someone's gonna have strong
words on the internet but that's why
using her in this sort of Twisted
assassination plot makes for very good
drama tagashi needs to add boxes to
characters with their names and group
info on them I keep forgetting who is
who at this point that's fair enough and
that's something I really love about one
piece actually it's a series with
literally over a thousand characters so
the author very frequently makes use of
both introduction and perhaps more
frequently re-introduction boxes and
text and stuff to make sure that the
readers always know who's who and
sometimes even to make them know that
who's who is actually who's who yes
there's a character named who's who
because when you have over a thousand
characters you start running out of
names and you need to name people after
just basic pronouns to be honest though
I don't know if this approach would work
as well for Hunter Hunter I mean yes it
would convey information in a more clear
way but I think it might risk breaking
the immersion a bit this idea works well
for one piece because it's a fun Wacky
World where anything goes but hunter
hunter is a more grounded story and I
think that excessive text overlays could
make us very aware of the hand of the
author which I don't personally want I
just want to be immersed into this
particular world even if that means
often forgetting these characters and
needing to go back and find out who they
are with all that's happening I truly do
wonder if we will ever see our green
broccoli boy gone I mean I miss him yeah
so I wouldn't accountancy and gone
anytime soon but to get your broccoli
fix here is broccoli the boss of the
Chara family who has an infinitely
greater chance of appearing soon in
manga as opposed to gone so I hope that
this has satisfied your broccoli craving
will hisoka interact with any of the
princes if he goes to tier one I would
absolutely love that but I doubt it the
princes are just so damn hard to gain
access to and the succession War isn't
an event that's particularly friendly to
hisoka's very aggressive abilities with
the exception of the ever sneaky texture
surprise but really this war is more
about stuff like remote controlling
cockroaches to spy on all of your
enemies but if there is one Prince I
could see hisoka interacting with it is
definitely Tyson because she would be
absolutely smitten with our very pretty
murder clown she would go insane for him
the rest of the prince's own probably
not I really don't call this a real
Hiatus the way they announced it was
more of a change of release schedule
than a proper Hiatus which is of course
great so to clarify this is only a
Hiatus because we have no official
return to date although the word Hiatus
is very Broad in fact a series can go on
here it is for only a single week but I
agree this is not a Hiatus in the hunter
hunter meaning of the word we're more or
less in a transitional period where
Togashi and his staff are trying to
figure out a method of manga
productionment that is both consistent
and caters to tagashi's health needs
which again is much better news than
we've had in the past where the
announcement was just and we're on Hades
now full stop and this one in particular
is a great chance to reread the
succession War before we dive into the
next batch of chapters because chapter
400 even through me off there was so
much print stuff that I had just pushed
to the back of my mind and all of a
sudden it was like oh yeah there's that
subplot over here and there's that
subplot over there and they're meeting
in the middle and the scary thing is as
much as 400 really tried to cram in it
doesn't even really scratch the surface
of all of the princely doings I mean
Benjamin Camilla saridnik hulkenberg
Mariam and luzaris all of these agendas
more than half of the prince is still
remaining to be checked in with again
all of them having their own unique
threads that were in theory meant to be
following I mean I say in theory because
because let's be real it's hard to
retain all of that information over a
long period of time so while unfortunate
this is not an entirely unwelcome Hiatus
I think the last chapters have given us
a lot to work with and think about and I
very much look forward to making a ton
of hunt videos whilst we wait for the
inevitable Return of the series